but that snowed you that [ __ ] is I mean
it's unnecessary isn't it
it is it is but at least you still made
it to all your shows on like Chris
D'Elia I think he was canceling the show
he canceled the show this week yeah
because of what cuz it's now oh my god
are you serious I'm pretty sure let me
say this let me say this too and you
know what actually let me say this man
I will never cancel the show here's what
things I won't do cancel a show I will
never canceled the show and let if I
have if I lose an arm you know I'm
saying say if it's you know I get in a
so you know somebody attacks me with a
sword or somebody you know I get you
know somebody slams an arm in a trunk in
a sharp trunk I'll be at my show dude I
got another [ __ ] arm and Chris D'Elia
with all those money he couldn't get an
umbrella or a snow hat or somebody poor
to just stand over him and knock the
snow away as it comes near him what yeah
god dude the rich man I'll tell you this
I will never be rich enough where I feel
like I don't have to perform from
audience you can always count on me I
don't care you I have I know six people
that have been hit by lightning six real
people for still alive and if you don't
think that I know that mother nature's
looking for me you don't just know that
many people that I'm hit by lightning
unless Mother Nature is trying to track
your ass down
that's like lightning going door-to-door
[ __ ] looking for you
and I know I'm next but I still go out
there every day and do my work I'm like
that these [ __ ] say I'm sorry man I
mean get fired up that [ __ ] makes me mad
I hear ya if you want if you want to
hear his excuses I just sent you the the
link to his tweet where he apologizes
okay yeah man let me maybe take a look
at that sweet real quick cuz I don't
like to do this gospel but I do like to
see this kind of
I do you like to see what my peers are
up to and not up to Oh st. Louis but let
me play this [ __ ] he says it verbally
let's hear this st. Louis so listen I
can't get there whoa I can't get there
let me think of what year it is - mm
probably 2019
there's hundreds of ways to get sled um
horseback
car motor car motor home you could [ __ ]
him be in a home and just get there okay
hitchhike plane helicopter ropes course
what else did he say
I tried look into flying I tried to
whoa-ho
you tried look at it a flying who are
you one of the [ __ ] Wright brothers
just get on a plane bro I was there
how far is st. Louis from can we look
that up if you don't mind Nicholas how
far st. Louis which is a city is from
another place where I was Omaha Nebraska
and I'm gonna bet it is eight hours it
is six hours 23 minutes 432 miles damn I
wish you two told me how to come over
and done his show for him let's hear
more Drive I tried to even leave last
night but they're just everything's
blocked off and I can't blocked off by
what huh
Oh curse what um what army military the
wall what are you talking about let's
hear more get there for the show tonight
I feel extremely horrible and I worked
it out to where I rescheduled the date
to February 24th Wow this reminds me of
a stepdad this is something like a
stepdad does you know or a dad that
doesn't really like to take care of his
babies you know it doesn't really handle
his children let's hear this excuse that
would this put the excuse part again
rescheduled the date to can take your
baseball game so I can't be at your
graduation forming at the same theater a
lot of your mom and at this other lady
tickets
you bought or completed your baseball
game for February at your graduation at
the Stifel theater love you let me get
this apartment across town I tried
everything here base Calder I still love
your mom buy-in so wish I could be there
I'll see ya every 24 did you get my
Christmas card funds will be granted ya
can wish I could be there and I'm really
a small game but forgive me still up in
Lamba the apartment complex has a pool
Wow sorry I'm [ __ ] down a zoned out
there but there you go guys and I was at
my shows and I will be in Kansas City
I'm gonna make it up for Chris D'Elia
since he can't be there I'm going to if
you come to my shows in Kansas City and
you dress up like Chris D'Elia I am
going to have a gift for you I'm not
sure what it is but I'm have something
special because you know I'm the kind of
guy that takes care of his team so can't
beat your facebook good evening good
afternoon and other times thanks for
watching that video you just saw I mean
it was okay but the next video you can
watch could be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one watch this
one watch this one watch this one